so the following video you're about to
see is a talk I gave at the district of
the South's annual conference that's a
part of the Orthodox Church the Orthodox
Church of America and so the reason why
I'm making this introduction is because
for those of you who a lot of the videos
that I've been making I've been making a
big effort to speak with words that are
understandable to everyone but in this
particular talk I was surrounded by
priests and and the Archbishop of the
south and so possibly some of the words
that are being used will be difficult
for people who are coming from the
outside to understand and so what I've
done is I'm going to put a glossary it's
close enough to a glossary of words in
the description for a few basic things
and then I'm also going to try to add
more images into the presentation so
that it's as clear as possible for those
who who are chanting upon this Oh a last
thing is that I've been receiving a lot
of messages from people who question
whether or not the types of things I'm
talking about whether or not they're in
line let's say with what actual
Christians believe a lot of people have
been telling me that that my version of
Christianity is is really nice but that
you know that's not what people in the
church believe and so I considered that
I would like you to ponder that I was
surrounded by at least was it 100 150
clergy plus their wives and their
families and the Archbishop of the south
and although I'm sure some people didn't
like my talk no one was freaked out that
what I was saying and no one was acting
as if I was speaking completely against
the tradition so having said all that I
present to you a tentacles for the
zombie apocalypse your eminence
and Reverend father's I want to thank
you for this this opportunity
to speak you when I gave the title of my
talk I didn't know I would be speaking
during the dinner and so it's just a
rather awkward time to talk about
zombies so so I decided I was going to
spare you the grisly details and so I've
chosen images that are cartoons and from
children's images and so actually
although they're meant to be whimsical
and funny they might be more frightening
because that's what they're trying to be
so we live in a time of monsters I
announce this you but I think all of you
already know that we only need to glance
at popular culture to realize this at
the narrative level of our culture and
our stories we've become obsessed with
monsters with the strange aliens with
the marginal with the glorification of
the exception of things that don't fit
most of us here probably grew up with
Sesame Street where we were told that
monsters are our friends and it's no
longer in fiction by now the monsters
have left the dark space is under our
beds they have left our nightmares to
come out into the open at a social level
we can feel and see all around us the
growing polarization the acceleration of
what we can only call the breakdown the
decomposition of culture a progressive
dissipation of the center which rallies
us as a society and in thinking about
this it's difficult not to to reminisce
it's difficult not to to meditate on the
famous poem
by Yeats the second coming and we tend
to go back to that poem because it seems
at least in our most more frightening
moments we get the feeling that the
horrific cycle of the 20th century is is
on our horizon again turning and turning
in the widening gyre the Falcon cannot
hear the falconer Things Fall Apart the
center cannot hold
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
the blood-dimmed tide is loosed and
everywhere the ceremony of innocence is
drowned the best lack all conviction
while the worst are full of passionate
intensity this poem of which I've quoted
the first part is probably one of the
most known in modern poetry the most
cited I think it's actually the most
anthologized poem there is and it rings
so true because we stand here in that
widening widening gyre at the edge of
the world world where the wheel is
spinning so fast feels as if it's going
to come off its axis
and it is here on the edge that we find
the zombies wandering aimlessly in a
world that's losing its center unlike
most of his monstrous Ami's design life
unlike most of his monstrous brothers
let's say the zombie is truly the
harbinger of contemporary nihilism the
zombie has no magic the arrival of the
zombie usually has no clear reason but
rather the zombie is couched in a in a
biological accident a disease a plague
it's simply an animated corpse the
zombie inhabits the indeterminate space
of living death roaming around in packs
the zombie shows us the mindless
wandering of the mindless mob with an
insatiable hunger for devouring others
for swallowing life if the vampire is
the monster of aristocracy the zombie is
the monster of the mass of the demos the
monster of the accidental of
quantitative leveling the zombie is the
atheist insistence on the illusion of
free will it's an image of nihilism and
in idiosyncrasy taken all the way to
decomposition in every major city in
north america they have these events
they call them zombie walks and people
dress up as zombies and walk into
thousands down the streets dressed up
and made up to look like corpses
shifting around with dead empty eyes
pretending to be the walking dead
some of these are huge if we were
generous we could say that it is a
zombie procession we could call it you
could say that there liturgical zombies
if there's such a thing the zombie vote
typifies the mob while simultaneously
the absolute individualism the absolute
isolation of contemporary life the
zombies in a horde only interacts with
what they desire and they never interact
with each other and the crop' of
cannibalism is very ancient it's there
in all the ancient stories all the
ancient myths but the tweak in zombies
on that theme of desiring to eat the
brain it's a very powerful one because
it's truly the image of the nihilist
because the zombie is a creature without
meaning without intelligence it misses
any form of personhood and
has this insatiable desire with mirror
which mirrors what it lacks it desires
what it lacks identity meaning and this
desire appears in that materialist
reduction of identity and personhood to
that clump of cells that we have up in
our cranium the zombie wants to eat your
brains because it cannot eat the mind
and it cannot inhabit the mind but
strangely enough this desire to eat the
living is the extreme perversion of our
desire for a communion and it's also a
distilled image of all our passions our
attempt to fill the unquenchable
yearning through our passion always
transforms other people into commodities
that we think will bring us what we need
so the zombie is both an image of the
social breakdown the person as a
meaningless statistic the disappearance
of common values except the overwhelming
desire to consume but so it is also the
breakdown of the person itself into a
soulless desiring death machine there's
a strict analogy between these different
levels of the world the social breakdown
and polarization is to the state with
the abandonment to the passions is for
the person and the zombie is both of
those fragmentations at the same time so
as we pull back a bit as we look around
at the narrative fabric of our world
begins to fill in quantities that are
barely possible to believe with images
of the monstrous as we feel the world
being torn apart by fragmentation and
conflict we are simultaneously as
individuals being constantly assaulted
by images images with the purpose of
awakening our own desires and we've come
to the point where we most of us so many
of us have been accustomed
to the constant exposure to the stranger
and stranger fringe of desire while
being enticed by the siren song to
indulge to give in to the waves under
storm and to sink into the mire now as
we here hopefully who still hold on to a
liturgical world not the zombie kind the
divine kind a world which strives out of
pattern and purpose we can both stand in
a church where Christ in the dome is the
origin of the heavenly hierarchy of
beings we and we also know that we can
find hezekiah in our heart in our Center
as a gateway to the divine and as the
manager of the passions whirling in the
widening gyre just like our individual
unholy unions with death appear on the
edge of our beings wear to an excessive
attachment to our senses we mingle with
our passions and produce our own
aberrations the cosmic monster lies on
the edge of the world the edge and the
end of the world those two things the
edge and the end they represent the same
structure they're the same thing in our
stories and so even when he is a zombie
man is the microcosm
the notion that a movement towards the
edge and a movement towards the end are
similar nature is one which is right
there in the beginning of scripture when
Adam and Eve fall they are told that
they will die but that's not immediately
what happens is it in fact what happens
is they move away from the central tree
past the walls of the garment of the
garden and out into the wilderness and
similarily Adam and he moves out from
the center into history Adam and Eve are
given garments of skin an outer layer of
animality and outer an outer layer of
death to protect them from death and if
our mind is struggling to get a sense of
what that what that means it's very
difficult to understand what that means
that we were given a protection of death
a layer of death to protect us from
death I always think of a vaccine it's
probably the best image for that the
garments of skin is seen by the church
fathers as all that is added to our
nature in the world of the fall the
layers of society of Technology and
those are the flipside and in a way
they're of the same nature as our
weakness and the passions with which
come from the world of death st. Gregory
of Nyssa tells us that the hairs on our
body are a symbol of death that without
feeling and dead and appear as our
spatial extremities the very limit of
our garments of skin just as death
appears as our temporal extremity of
this earthly life the Giants in the
Bible
those that appeared before the flood
with a sign of confusion and mixture
wrapped in inappropriate sexual desire
in the tradition of Enoch they are seen
as the origin of technology and magic
and they were known to create hybrids
they're full of excess reveling in
conflict until absolute chaos could no
longer be held at bay and the world was
undone in the waters the ceremony of
innocence was drowned in sophisticated
hybrid non binary fluid categories and
in a very parallel way the ancients
described the world geographically as a
giant island surrounded by a vast ocean
whose fringes were inhabited by
impossible monsters these signs of the
the breakdown and the confusion the
confusion of categories which is death
basically
the cosmic garments of skin these images
that I'm showing you are based on the
descriptions of the faraway races by the
first century Pliny the Elder who died
during the Vesuvius eruption that which
destroyed Pompeii so now imagine how
plenty the elder would have described
these faraway specimens but I need to be
careful because as we stand here
possibly in that widening gyre possibly
nearing the teetering edge of the world
it would be too easy to point and say
there they are right there they are the
degenerate ones there they are the
monsters and thank God we're safe in the
church and like I mentioned and like
I'll be saying all through this talk the
same chaos which lies on the edge of the
world also lies on the edge of each one
of us but I think it's still possible
though to to to look around and to read
the signs of the time so how do we make
sense of this as we look around us and
find the flood waters rising
how do we navigate through the growing
chaos in the back of my mind there's a
saying which plays over and over maybe
in the hopes of convincing myself and it
is the last promise made by Christ
before his ascension behold I am with
you until the end of the age and we know
as Orthodox Christian that this promise
also implies that Christ is with us
until the limits of the world with us
until the bottom of the world the bottom
of death where Christ crushed the head
of the serpent as she descended into
Hades the promise Christ made when he
was about to ascend to the Father the
promise of Pentecost it echoes the
promise of the Spirit that he made in
the gospel of Saint John chapter 14
Pentecost is the possibility of moving
in Christ from the Upper Room from the
top from the highest place or from the
center let's say no matter how you frame
it but to move in Christ until the end
of the world until the end of the age it
is the church a blaze a fire that
spreads and consumes until the age
itself in consume wood like the fire
that Moses saw on the Sinai the church
is not consumed
the icon of Pentecost is a cosmic image
it shows us a type of multiplicity a
type of multiplicity which is not
fragmentation a type of multiplicity
which is not the decomposition of our
times what is a multiplication which
does not forget its center in the terms
of the of the field kaliya as we move
into multiplicity Pentecost is the
possibility of the remembrance of God
the remembrance of God even unto death
if we look at the image we see the icons
are seated in an arch which is a proxy
of the church itself the icon of
Pentecost is one of those icons which
although it does represent an event in
the Bible it represents it in a manner
that goes beyond the event and becomes a
permanent image of how the church exists
in the world and the hint that this is
the case is that although st. Paul was
not there at the event of the Bible he
is represented in this icon and here st.
Peter and st. Paul are represented
together as the pillars of the church as
the left hand and right hand of Christ
above the Apostles is the holy fire
which descends on them this fire
separates into twelve just as the
Apostles themselves each acquired
tongues of fire tongues which speak in a
manner that can reveal Christ through
multiplicity and be heard by all men and
then down in the bottom of the icon is
the door which leads outside the upper
room it is the door which leads out into
the outer darkness and in the door is
represented the allegorical figure of
the cosmos itself which holds the
scrolls the fully manifest form of the
twelve traditions issued by the one fire
the one church whose unity is preserved
in its multiplicity
and of course the door of Pentecost is
the door of the church itself the church
considered at all levels of
interpretation that we can understand
that statement it's both the door of the
church in the sense of the cosmic body
of Christ but it's also the door on the
building of your local church the door
which leads out of the nave out of the
narthex into the chaotic outside now in
earlier traditions of the Pentecost what
was represented in the door was not the
synthetic image of cosmos and the very
earliest images that I could find in
this form of Pentecost they all come
from
right after iconoclasm and they
represent an empty door but very soon in
the door was represented a crowd of
foreigners all with different hats and
different clothing and and different
shades of skin color this is one of my
is one of my favorite versions it's from
a from a serbian monastery and here the
door of pentecost is actually a window
which leads outside of the church and
the foreigners appear coming towards the
church from the edge on the sides
there's a tradition from Armenia which
portrays a monster in the door of
Pentecost the monster is either a dog
headed man I see no cephalus or L that
is truly an unnameable monster a kind of
chaotic being with a dog face growing
behind its head this was the image that
I chose at the first slide of my
presentation now the first time I saw
this image I came across it in a book
and I was startled beyond belief
I mean I guess you can imagine but as I
began to understand the image of
Pentecost I realized to what extent this
is a testimony to the totality of what
Christianity is meant to be to the true
possibility of God being all in all the
monster as an inhabitant of the margin
is a token of that which does not fit
within what we know cannot be measured
in the categories that we are aware of
it appears as a as a freak as the
ultimate unexpected so monster the
monster is both encounter with the
surprise of the future as we move
forward in time so to encounter the
unexpected the monster is also the
encounter with the surprise of the edge
as the church expands to the dark
corners of the world but also the dark
corners of our own lives as the Spirit
of God transforms us for most of us
there are always be foreign elements
monsters hiding in our garments of skin
so here in Pentecost this monster is
represented as not yet in the church but
as part of the potential into which the
church can grow as part of that which
can hear the gospel in its language now
I want to issue
I just before I keep going I want to
issue a caveat if there are some
cryptozoologists in the room or like
conspiracy types who who talked about
lizard-men who live under the earth like
you don't you don't have to identify
yourself but this next part is for you
we have to be extremely careful when we
read ancient accounts we don't we don't
want to interpret that wheter prett them
in our rather materialistic categories
of genus and species in the Bible a bird
is an animal with wings so a bat is a
bird and a fish is something in the
water so whales and dolphins are fish
and so we don't have to imagine some
kind of cenote cephalic people out there
that would have some genetic
relationship to dogs anymore than we
used to think that a hippopotamus or a
river horse need have a genetic genetic
relationship with horses just as the
ancient called those they could not
understand barbarians that is those who
bark like dogs the notion of dog headed
man appears as this encounter with an
aspect of humanity which we can barely
see because they're far so far removed
from our capacity to properly see them
if I if I hear someone speaking
Cantonese I am NOT going to understand
that I will hear chaos and if it's
difficult to have that experience now
because we've seen everything but if you
just maybe imagine seeing an Australian
Bushman 500 years ago the it is possible
to see chaos but the notion of the sino
cephalus has an important history in
Christianity it comes of course from the
clinic past from the legends of
Alexander the Great
but the image of the dog headed man
became the central image of the
Christian edge of the world
the ultimate hostile foreigner and
personally I think that it partly became
so important because of its strong
analogies in the Bible Christ speaks of
the Canaanite woman and he told her that
one should not give two dogs the bread
that is meant for the children and the
answer of the Canaanite woman is
analogous to what we see in this icon
that even the dogs eat the crumbs that
fall from their master's table so here
in the icon of Pentecost and see this
dog not so much at the end of the table
but maybe on the edge of the church
maybe on the edge of the world this one
is not a Canaanite but a Canaanite and
that might seem like a really bad pun
but I assure you that it will cause
modern interpreters to cry foul in
reading these ancient accounts and will
say that all of this question is just a
matter of bad transcription I don't
think so all these foreigners in the
icon of Pentecost culminating into the
impossible monster are the surprise we
discover on the edge of the church
anticipating maybe waiting for the
crumbs maybe waiting for the anti door
on which we can imagine flowing out of
the church so that even those we can
barely recognize as our brothers can
have a foretaste of the kingdom of
heaven now the most famous dog headed
man some of you know where I'm going
with this is of course st. Christopher
st. Christopher's traditional icon
represents him as a dog headed warrior
there are many who have tried to say
that this tradition of st. Christopher
as the dog headed man is late and like I
said is just a misunderstanding of
ancient texts and I don't know it
depends what you mean by late this is a
the first image of st. Christopher we
have it's from the 6th or the 7th
century so it's before iconoclasm which
means that we're lucky we even have this
image there are probably many more but
they've just been destroyed by the
iconoclast it's a ceramic icon depicting
him next to st. George
each killing snakes
and this is just one of my favorite
images in the world so here's the the
monster and the monster killing the
monster killer - warriors facing the
Dragons and it's funny how they they
they keep telling us that the legend of
Saint Christopher killing the dragon is
you know from the 12th century or
something so yeah it always seems like
scholars are are telling Christian that
we're deluding ourselves and that a
world cannot exist without a textual
reference but here it is so there was an
attempt to eliminate this icon and the
Russians anodal period because it did
not fit modern sensibilities and I've
had many people especially priests tell
me that they're really bothered by this
icon and it's funny because although I
have tried to explain it in a certain
manner defend it for example I wrote an
article about Saint Christopher and the
Orthodox our chill
it is one of our most popular articles
it has been viewed over 20,000 times
when an article about a dog headed Saint
is one of your most popular articles I
would call that a sign of the times
people but having said that I would be a
bit disturbed myself if we were not at
least bothered by this icon I mean my
goodness it is a dog headed man after
all and I think that in a way that
that's the point I think that that's the
point I always like to say that st.
Christopher the icon is st. Christopher
is the last icon it's on the very edge
of iconography and because it is so it
will always appear as ambiguous and
straddle the border of what is
acceptable or unacceptable in icons in
the Greek tradition the icon has st.
Christopher was actually placed above
the exit door of the church so that it
would be the last thing you saw going
out into the world
and in the West and Christopher was
placed on bridges where he would
represent the uneasy space of the
transition in between space I think that
Christopher is crucially important to
understand right now basically I think
that st. Christopher is the patron saint
at the end of the world and although
he's not my official patron I would say
that he's he come so unofficially having
lived abroad for many years and having
traveled much I've witnessed many
miracles and as he many signs
surrounding his presence in my life so
this is the icon that hangs one of the
icons that hangs in my workshop and also
I think that will need st. Christopher
when the zombies come so as we face the
rising chaos as we face the zombies we
recall the world the words of the
psalmist I am surrounded by my enemies
who are like lions hungry for human
flesh the immediate danger is that we
become afraid like st. Peter walking on
the waters there's a trope in zombie
stories according to which no matter how
bad the situation is no matter how bad
the zombies tried to get in the true
danger lies within the true danger lies
and how the human group shuts themselves
off and completely isolates themselves
and become pathological in their
isolation
the fear of facing the possibility of
the flood is to think that as in the
story of Noah the door of the church
must be closed and sealed shut
[Music]
maybe we can get together and isolate
ourselves completely I mean it's
tempting isn't it and we've heard some
informations of that tendency recently
but Christ promised us that the gates of
Hell will not prevail on the doors of
the church and I'm not saying here there
isn't a time to seal the door of the
church obviously that's what we do at
least symbolically after the exit of the
catechumens we should and must protect
our mysteries in fact rather seems
sometimes that we've been sheepish in
doing so I want to show you something
once I encountered an image of Pentecost
from a medieval Coptic Church can you
see the difference the first time I saw
an icon of Pentecost where the door was
closed and it disturbed me profoundly to
see such an image and it took time
before I understood why such an image
would even have come into existence and
I realized at least I speculated that
the cops had become so beset on all
sides of their opponents had been so
besieged in their Dimmie status that it
was inevitable that they represent the
door of Pentecost as closed and it's
food for thought but to see such an
image to make us weep and pray that even
as we become besieged we find a way to
keep the door of Pentecost open for if
we close those doors we abandon the
world to its fragmentation
so once I tell you the story of st.
Christopher you've all heard it I want
to tell it maybe in a different way the
version of the story which we know best
actually comes from the Western
tradition and the Western tradition st.
Christopher is not a dog headed man but
a giant he's not a Canaanite but a
Canaanite and an important way he's a K
Knight that is a descendants of Cain who
associated with the Nephilim the Giants
of the Genesis flood so although he's
not a dog headed man in the Western
tradition and some people have felt safe
and represented this version of the icon
in their churches because they didn't
like the dog headed version and that's
understandable but even though he's a
canine st. Christopher is still like the
Canaanite woman that dog on the edge of
the table who asks Christ for the crumbs
so as hard as you try you will not get
the dog out of st. Christopher these are
a few hybrid icons joining the Western
tradition with the eastern one the sort
of Saint Christopher has them as a
vicious warrior in Canaan who is looking
to serve the most powerful man in the
world he found the most renowned and
powerful King until he sees that this
king is afraid of the devil so he goes
to serve the devil and in this we can
see st. Christopher going all the way to
the end all the way to what to the edge
of what is imaginable in becoming a
servant of the Evil One directly
then st. Christopher notice is that the
evil one is afraid of the cross so he
decides he will serve Christ and when
the story at least in the Virgin in the
version that's in the golden legend
Saint Christopher is also a trickster
because he tells those he serves for
example he informs the king that unless
the King tells them who the devil is
that he will no longer serve that king
but in answering Saint Christopher this
becomes the very reason why Saint
Christopher stops serving the king and
then looks for the next most powerful
person which is the devil and then he
does the same to the devil he tricks the
devil himself
in revealing Christ to him we need to
pay attention to this detail because I
think it's an it's it's an image of what
st. Christopher can be for us the key to
the double inversion which transforms
the fall and death into resurrection the
trampling of death by death in a search
for Christ he comes to a hermit in the
desert who teaches him the way of
Christianity but when it comes to the
practice Saint Christopher cannot follow
the rule cannot follow the standard I
mean he is a monster after all the
Hermit says too fast
to abstain st. Christopher replies that
he cannot the Hermit says to pray I
think st. Christopher says he cannot so
the Hermit says to think that st.
Christopher should stand next to the
river and cross those who need to cross
on his shoulders I want you to notice
how profound the story becomes here we
often think of the Ark built by Noah as
a holy thing and a certain way it is
we often imagine the knave or even the
whole church of the holy thing and in
many ways it is but in another very very
important way the Ark is a boat full of
beasts and the church is a hospital full
of the sick so since Christopher stands
on the edge of the world she stands on
the bank of the flood when the logos the
Christ Immanuel who is the logos
implicit the seed of God in all things
comes to the edge well it is the monster
like an art who can carry him across I
want you to think of that hermit you see
the Hermit did not tell Saint
Christopher that it was fine that he
could not follow fasting and prayer I
mean he didn't say that since Saint
Christopher you know thought that it was
against his nature to fast and pray the
Hermit didn't tell them that the church
had been wrong all along
no but the Hermit in in wisdom and in
economía he brought Saint Christopher to
the edge he brought Saint Christopher
into the narthex on the edge of the
flood where he could be the ambiguous
figure he was in the first place and
eventually and mysteriously become a
vehicle for his Lord
there's a woman who comes to our parish
her name is Marlon Marlon is homeless
and so and if sometimes she's able to
find a place to stay it never lasts long
she's never able to find stability
there's something some thrust in her
which makes it impossible to remain
stable generous people from the parish
have tried to help her find a place to
help her find some stability but never
last long Marlon is a hermaphrodite her
appearance is confusing as she straddles
the limits of what we understand
straddles the limits of the normal
categories that constitute the world
Marlon is paranoid and possibly more
when you speak with her she jumps from
one thing to the next one subject to the
next conversation is disjointed and
fragmented to speak with her as to feel
like she's constantly under attack
Marlon comes and sits in the narthex and
she was he stayed there for the whole
service and very rarely she she gets up
and she walks into the nave and she sits
down in the nave which he always stays
just for a few minutes and then she
returns to the narthex we've invited her
to commend our priest has spoken to her
asked her if she wanted to be catechized
if she wanted to join and join into full
communion but Marlon returns to the
narthex she waits until coffee our she
eats with us and hopes that someone will
give her some money before she leaves
margin is Marlon has memorized the
services sometimes she makes little
comments about some detail you know some
small error or confusion in the service
maybe the choir was off a little bit
maybe someone forgot some small detail
and she knows what's happening in the
parish the politics and the jostling
which sometimes takes place in human
affairs and we hear strands of that we
hear these hyper lucid comments the
Epirus surprises in her usual frenetic
conversation when sunday Marjolein
reached into her backpack she she
carries this backpack around with her
and she reached into her backpack and
she took out these three small mcdonald
toys you know the kind of toy you get if
you buy a Happy Meal and she took these
three toys and she gave them to my
children so there's a tradition in
Indian culture according to which to
receive a gift from a beggar is to
receive a blessing from God
there are those who whisper in the
parish I don't know who but there's
someone who whispering in the parish
that maybe Marlon is an angel
once in speaking to her she told me that
she also attends a mosque that there is
a Muslim couple who will often pick her
up on Friday so that she can participate
in the prayer I would ask all of you in
that last sentence that I just added to
that story all of us to examine what our
hearts did when I added that last part
there are some of us here who might be
too happy that I mentioned the detail
about the mosque and there are some here
who might be too annoyed that I
mentioned that detail but Marjolein just
sits in the narthex after all there's
something about the margin which always
arises our passions and so I hope that I
brought all of you to a place that
you're struggling to deal with the
threat of zombies the abundance of
monsters Saint Christopher dog headed
men people who don't fit into categories
if you feel uneasy and a bit conflicted
and confused that I was able to move
from zombies to angel in one fell swoop
I'm sorry I have to apologize that was
really the point of my talk
that's what fragmenting looks like
that's what a fragmented age looked like
the moment when order is not easy to
inhabit because the world is filled with
exceptions there's something deeply out
of place that I am here at a church
conference talking about zombies but
that's where we are that's where we are
in the world if we think we can deal
with this age by simply shutting the
door of the church we are going to be in
serious
trouble and if we think we can deal with
this age by letting in the flood waters
there is going to be serious
trouble as well so now what do we do
well how do we live how do we love
properly in an age of division and caste
first I think we need to look at the
icon of Pentecost with some humility the
chaos of the edge and the end is death
but chaos is also an opportunity for
renewal this was true for the Sabbath it
is true for baptism and it is true for
Holy Saturday and for goodness sake it's
true when we sleep most of us here are
here today because the rigid categories
which legislate Society are breaking
down they've been breaking down for
about three generations if I if I were
to ask everyone here what their ancestry
is how many are immigrants are children
of immigrants I mean we are standing
here in a in a church which came from
Russia and here we are in the south of
the United States I am a french-canadian
Protestant who became an orthodox icon
carver we are the image of the
opportunity of Pentecost I mean with
this gathering here would have even been
possible 50 years ago no there's no way
we can be here because in the breakdown
of categories things that usually would
not meet can in fact meet I believe it's
not for nothing that Christianity
increased in the twilight of the Roman
Empire where the stretched multi-ethnic
multicultural vastness was oscillating
between
fragmentation civil war the iron fist of
a Diocletian figure but here's the
kicker here here is the side effect the
surprising side effect of our
fragmentation right now as we are
watching the Western world being propped
up as competing identities of race and
gender you know an ethnicity and age and
you name it any identity you can imagine
and while simultaneously there's this
paradoxical insistence that all
identities and distiction distinctions
have to be dissolved there are those who
are not even in the church not in any
church who are getting an inkling that
maybe Christianity considered even at
its minimum as a set of presumptive
presuppositions maybe it was the only
glue that ever held the West together
that ever kept the balance since the
conversion of Rome even as precarious
and volatile as that unity sometimes was
and so I've been surprised to find
myself facing all these people these
atheists these people who don't believe
in anything who are suddenly looking at
Christianity and Christians
presuppositions but of course the same
breakdown to make no illusion about the
same breakdown of society which makes
this meeting possible which makes some
see that Christianity is valuable is
also the breakdown which makes the
zombie scratch at our door and it seems
that every exception every aberration
every proclivity is looking for its
moment in the Sun looking not only to
exist in the margin but to be given the
stamp a full official recognition but in
the rising flood in the world filled
with monsters people are looking for
meaning people are so hungry for meaning
for the past year so I have been on an
adventure on a crazy
adventure that took me completely by
surprise I was asked to do some
interview with some professor in Toronto
on some random subject and because of
that I'm not going to go into the
details but but all of a sudden I was
being flooded with letters and letters
of atheists atheists who are looking
around and are seeing the fragmentation
as well they're looking around and
they're seeing the hemorrhaging of our
culture and they're trying to ask what
can we do to stop the bleeding I mean
there are its ways but there's some
peers when I get a letter I get a long
email every day of some recovering
atheist who's moving away from their
criticism you know the 13 year olds
version of Christianity and is
discovering the cosmic vision of Christ
and he's discovering the cosmic vision
of his mother whose womb is faster than
the heavens there's so much to say to
those people I mean we hold in our
hearts the tradition of Christ which
connects through a beautiful braid of
analogies the personal the social the
cosmic and the transcendent realms I am
NOT I've not tried to convince anybody I
have no desire to convince anybody the
only thing that I ever did was to show
people the the beautiful patterns that
are in our tradition the beautiful
connections between Scripture and the
icons and the liturgy and the hymns and
people are so hungry for meaning that
they just it's like breathing it's like
it's like the all the sudden they've
been drowning and they can they can take
a breath I'm not saying that all these
people are going to become Orthodox I
mean I don't think so but it's a crazy
thing I got a letter from a man
a man from 2-3 days ago I got a letter
from a man in Pakistan a man who was a
Muslim and who in university like so
many people became an atheist and now he
writes me and he says I think I'm a
Christian I don't know and I don't know
what to do because I'm in Pakistan of
all the Christians we do not see the
stories of the Bible the stories of
salvation is just this arbitrary set of
facts that we must believe in to be
saved of all Christians we know the
organic process of salvation the
transformation of man into God through
participation in the life of God is a
very manner by which the world exists
it's the very thing that links this
outwards phenomena to consciousness to
news to logos and unites all things
towards the infinite I mean how awesome
is that
and in the background we've also kept
and we hold not only the keys to
Christianity we also hold the heritage
of the ancients I mean we're not
plaintiffs but we have carried Plato we
are not Aristotelian but we have carried
Aristotle Alexander Homer Virgil and we
could add to that you know all the
useful stories of all people who enter
in communion with Christ we keep them
alive in the narthex of the church so
that they can participate in the manner
to which it is possible that they
participate in the divine life you'll
recognize these are images of the Greek
sages from an earth X at a monastery in
Greece they don't have halos so it's
okay
we hold the golden thread that reaches
back into the midst of time the same
golden thread that is under increasing
threat of being cut so I think the chaos
we face is a test like the water the
baptism it will wash off all that is
superficial all that which we have not
integrated encountering outer darkness
being challenged by the outer darkness
is an urgent test for Christians to know
to the extent that it is possible to
know in our hearts and our minds what
exactly is this thing about what is the
Incarnation how does it anchor the world
and of course there is mystery but we
can tell people why mistery matters why
some things cannot be described or
contained and why that mystery is the
fount of existence and I think that the
answer and how to engage the fragmenting
world is in the story of Saint
Christopher but as we travel further
away from the altar we never compromise
its purity as we move to the nave and
through the narthex
as we move out in a candlelit procession
out into the world our compassion grows
as Christ's compassion grew facing the
adulterous woman as Christ's compassion
grew vaiting the rich thieving tax
collector the heretical Samaritan woman
all of this we can do without
compromising the purity of the altar the
rigour of the sacramental life Christ
protected the purity of the holy place
he cleared the temple of lies and
corruption and Christ can hold a whip in
his left hand and blessed with his right
hand we we need not confuse the altar
with the narthex
and in fact we offer that very structure
to the world the very structure of the
church itself as a ladder and we're
willing to plant that first bar plant it
unapologetically into the mud maybe into
the very belly of hell but we know that
it reaches all the way to the heaven of
heaven but as we preserve preserve the
hierarchy of salvation we must remain
cautious we must remain humble enough to
notice the holy fool who's hiding in the
chaos the exception who reminds us that
hierarchy is for us and not for God who
is beyond all distinction we need to be
humble enough to perceive that sometimes
even if it is rarely are the grace of
our Lord the monster on the edge of the
world will be the very vehicle for
Christ to be carried further out than we
ever thought possible thank
you